the seasons are always changing but Game
of Thrones fans know that everything is
just one long winter until the final
season of the series arrives in 2019
until the show returns to air though all
we can really do is speculate here are
all the rumors about Game of Thrones
final season a bloody end for Arya
Maisie Williams who plays Arya posted a
picture to her Instagram of her sneakers
covered in blood on her last day of
shooting that seems to imply that her
final scene will involve some seriously
bloody combats but will Arya survive
what do we say to the god of death at
stake either way she says that the final
filming for her character took place in
Belfast where the scenes in Winterfell
in the north are shot
based on this geotag flew alone it seems
like however her bloody story ends it'll
be in the north brother from another
mother lena headey also dropped a sneaky
reference to season 8 on her own
Instagram after snapping a pic with her
on-screen brothers Peter Dinklage and
Nikolaj coster-waldau captioned
congratulations to my brothers literally
from other mothers I'm a lucky lucky
sister to these mistis his Headey
insinuating that Tyrians parentage is a
bit more complicated than it seems
multiple sources including the
independents have speculated that tyrion
is actually the bastard son of Joanna
Lannister and Aerys Targaryen making him
Daenerys his half-brother of course PD
uses the word mother's not father
so maybe he D is just making a cute
Instagram post Sansa in charge when we
first catch up with Sansa in season 8
she's going to be ruling the roost at
Winterfell while John is away however in
an interview with Digital Spy actress
sophie Turner mentioned that she's
wrapped shooting in Spain
that's where Dragonstone and the dragon
pit are filmed which means that although
Sansa might be running Winterfell at the
start of the season she's going to wind
up heading south at some point in
addition Watchers on the wall reports
that filming at the Roman ruins of
Italica in Spain aka the dragon pit were
scheduled for over four weeks hinting
that the location will be a far greater
importance in season 8 this news feeds
into the abundance of rumors that Santa
is going to come away the ultimate
winner of the game of Thrones now
I'm sure cutting off heads is very
satisfying but that's not the way you
get people to work together some fans
have even theorized that she might end
up marrying Gendry and become the queen
of the Seven Kingdoms give these boys a
hand in an interview with W radio at
Bogota Comic Con Nikolaj coster-waldau
revealed that Jaime will be interacting
with Liam Cunningham's Davos for the
first time this season since Davos is
currently serving as Jon Snow's hand the
news of their impending interactions
confirms the theory that Jamie is going
to make it all the way north to team up
with Jon and Daenerys return of the Bear
Queen played by Bella Ramsay Lyanna
Mormont was instrumental in installing
Jon Snow as king in the north in season
six
he's my king from this day until his
last day according to the Watchers on
the wall Ramsay was spotted on set in
Belfast implying that she's still
involved in the game however will she be
withdrawing her support when she learns
that her King has bent the knee to a
foreign Queen biggest battle ever in a
now-deleted Instagram post assistant
director Jonathan Quinlan captioned a
thank you note to the crew 55
consecutive nights eleven weeks three
locations you'll never again see
anything like it Quinlan's thank-you
note mentioned that the crew had been
working tirelessly in Northern Ireland
based on the show's previous filming
locations it's safe to assume that this
record-breaking massive battle will take
place in the north and it's likely to be
the final battle against the night king
ending at King's Landing rumours from
the Dubrovnik Times indicate that the
last scene of the entire series may very
well take place at King's Landing
nothing is official of course but
wouldn't the home of the Iron Throne be
a fitting location to end the series all
about the fight for said seat of power
the missing mountain interviewed in
January 2018 half-door ulysse Ornstein
who plays sir gregor at the mountain
pluggin wasn't all that forthcoming
about his involvement in season 8
this led fans to speculate over whether
this meant bjornsen wouldn't be on set
for long
well the mountain finally fall to the
Hound and the long awaited battle fans
clamouring for maybe Aria will finally
manage to cross his name off her list
plenty of death get ready to say goodbye
to at least some of your favorites in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter
HBO senior VP francesca Orsi explained
that the final moments of Game of
Thrones are going to spell doom for
multiple characters talking about the
final table read with the entire cast
she said none of the cast had received
the scripts prior and one by one they
started to fall down to their deaths by
the end the last few words and the final
script the tears just started falling
down when you play the game of Thrones
you win or you die there is no middle
ground
[Music]